there's just no bottom to the chaos in
California as folks lose their bottoms
and their tops a naked lady with a gun
jumping out of her car on his Bridge in
San Francisco and firing at people at
random oh my God oh my God oh my God oh
my God
it's a lady whoa I think she's ran out
she ran out holy oh man it's like a
video game she was arrested and
hopefully got dressed and in the name of
equality a naked man terrorizing
residents of an East Hollywood apartment
building The Creep walking outside the
place while carrying around a huge knife
but the cops say they are powerless to
stop him because it's not against the
law that's good news for me Joe Rogan
thinks this kind of stuff will Doom the
state's liberal leader Gavin Newsom if
he ever tries to run for president
it's California and Justin Trudeau it's
Gavin Newsom the problem is uh he did
such a bad job with California it's so
they're so vulnerable
Madness yeah close there's so many
businesses that are closing down they
don't want to be a part of it anymore
like hey we need to uh take care of
disenfranchised people but we also need
to make our streets safe and we have to
stop crime and there's no none of that
there's like more ridiculous laws more
lacks on crime more money for the
homeless people give them free drug give
them needles they need clean needles
like what
yeah because we're doing Jessica first
day Jessica
is and phenomenally true how is Gavin
immune to criticism he's going to be
your nominee when Joe drops out you guys
get rid of Kamala each and he's in The
Slammer oh I wish but I mean he almost
got recalled uh he's a he's probably a
good candidate but a terrible governor
no I well he was recalled but he won by
the same margins that he had won the
election guy so do you trust the results
of that election Jessica I do I tend to
trust results generally speaking and all
institutions
no I think that you can have a healthy
dose of skepticism without being a
apology accepted no again I hate going
first
um
obviously the no thanks Sandra
that didn't feel patronizing
um obviously the numbers they lost a
huge amount of tax revenue when you look
at the numbers of the Surplus that they
had and they had historic surpluses and
have gone into having a deficit and
Gavin Newsom in his latest budget
proposal did cut it out with the
spending but they need people to move
home and they need corporations to move
back for that and it's not just kind of
the crime and I just last week yeah or
two weeks ago I was out in LA in San
Francisco and it does feel markedly
different than it used to for sure
um but I don't think
that it's just that I think people are
considering all sorts of things
obviously when they're deciding to move
the what's going on with the weather
there between wildfires and heat waves
and things like that it makes it less
appealing as well we I think Jessica hit
it on the best talking point Jesse blame
the nudity on he I.E climate change
hence extreme Maga Republicans are
causing nude crimes
Republicans those naked people what did
you say about naked people I said
they're never attractive right and I
include myself in that I'm more
attractive with clothes on but I'll
leave that to for you to find out later
yeah okay that's right quit Dancing
update on the naked lady shooting
weapons on the streets she has not been
charged yet
she's probably mentally ill she's not
been charged yet also um the guy with
the knife who was also naked
masturbating in front of children at the
apartment complex again has he been not
been charged yet and that we know is
wrong so just in in Gavin newsom's what
four years as Governor the homeless
population has gone up 14 and he spent
billions dollars more each year so he's
actually paying for more homeless people
and the crime has gone up double digits
so if you're running against Gavin
Newsom in a general election the
question is do you want California to
turn into the United States of America
and you show it visually you know you
show Gavin Newsom with his arm around
the fat naked lady busting caps on the
405. you show a time thing of San
Francisco San Francisco
it just disintegrates Venice Beach under
Gavin news it's all homeless people on
fentanyl that's how you do it because
visually this is the best way to
communicate to the American people the
disaster that Gavin newsom's done with
San Francisco and how that's going to go
throughout the rest of the country yeah
I mean if Republicans can't beat that
they don't deserve I mean it's amazing
Sandra I would say if you can't protect
Nancy Pelosi's husband yeah he's not
going to protect your husband yeah the
crime seems to be getting more and more
surreal absurd like I was when I saw
that for the first time I felt like that
was Grand Theft Auto you know I was
watching a video game
um and the investigation's ongoing
everything you need to know you can see
there she was randomly shooting at these
cars thankfully nobody's been injured
um but I don't know how much more we
need to learn other than somebody ran
out naked in the middle of Highway and
started firing the numbers are so bad in
California that you've got to feel for
people who don't have the money to flee
that stage right because if you've got
money like all the Hollywood actors and
actresses who said they're fed up with
the crime they're fed up with the
homeless and they're fed up with the
drugs they leave and they take their
kids and they put them in nice schools
probably in red States somewhere else in
the country Florida's got a lot of the
incoming residents Texas as well the
unemployment there above the national
average okay their growth is down pews
basically saying that their population
continues to diminish their homeless
rate you just said under Gavin Newsom
but since 2012 the homeless rate is up
43 so this isn't just a story of Gavin
Newsom this is a story of Democratic
Leadership you talked about its other
crimes as well it's homicides its
robberies are up 10 you park your car on
the street there you have you you you're
lucky if you come back and it's there
maybe somebody maybe an exaggeration but
it's happening a lot it's crime on crime
judge uh Sandra's got a good point it's
no longer like a Melting Pot in
California it's two camps the very rich
and those literally camping on the
street like there's nowhere else for
anybody to go no and that's why
everyone's leaving and that's why more
people are leaving California than any
other state and all of the facts that
everyone has outlined are are clear and
that's why Joe Rogan left California by
the way because he he didn't like it he
didn't want his family anywhere near
there seven out of 10 people in
California don't want the Gavin Newsom
to run but I'm going to throw a clinker
in the whole thing
this guy Gavin Newsom is smooth yeah
okay he can be asked about homelessness
like he was with Sean Hannity and he can
say he can admit to it he can be honest
about it and yet get out of it in a way
where you know it's a problem everywhere
we're doing everything we can I know
it's wrong he is a smooth talker and my
concern about the American voter and the
American electorate is they're not going
to say oh I don't want my my state out
of my country to be like California
they're going to say ah he seems like
such a nice guy he's so good looking his
wife is pretty he's got nice kids and
they'll make him you know the you know
the Manna From Heaven and he could get
elected
he's a smooth criminal is what you're
saying yeah Michael Jackson Doug show
and said yesterday when the plea deal
fell apart he said this is a great day
for gaviness
he's not plotting that oh that's what
they always say oh again oh you guys
tell me what's happening on the dumb
side yeah well you certainly won't
all right
that was mean I apologize Jessica and
that's a phony apology hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else